هناك عديد من التجارب
والمهام اللي راح تؤدونها في الفضاء لو
ندخل في بعض تفاصيل هذه التجارب بالنسبه
لكم
مهمتنا بالاساس هي مهمه علميه فباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء 14 تجربه علميه بحثيه رائده
يعني لاول مره في التاريخ باذن الله هذه
التجارب تعنى بمجالات متعدده اولها هي
ثلاث تجارب دوعويه تعليميه ستكون
لها علاقه بالتعاون مع الطلاب فهذه
التجارب كلها هدفها تحفيز الطلاب وتحفيز
الفضول لديهم في مجال الفضاء وباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء اربع تجارب علميه لها علاقه
بالخلايا المناعيه وهذه باذن الله حتكون
اول مره في التاريخ سنقوم بزراعه خلايا
مناعيه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى بحيث انه
نزرع الخلايا ون العلاجات مختلفه عليها
ونشوف مدى استجابتها في بيئه الجاذبيه
الصوره وهذه البحث لاول مره يجرى في
التاريخ بدعم سمو سيدي حفظه الله احب اضيف
على كلام زميلتي ريان انه سوف نقوم باجراء
سته تجارب في الطب البشري وهذا التجارب
تعنى بدراسه التغيرات على التي قد تصيب
الدماغ الجهاز العصبي العظام وكذلك النظر
هذه الدراسات سبق وتم اجرائها في بيئه
الجاذبيه الصغرى ولكن الجديد انه سوف يتم
استخدام اجهزه جديده لاول مره في الفضاء
بشانها المساعده في تسريع النتائج
والتحاليل ان شاء الله وكذلك في الاستمطار
الصناعي وهذا تجربه فيزيائيه تعتبر كاول
مره تحدث كذلك في الفضاء وهي من شانها او
كفيله نتائج هذه التجربه بزياده ورفع
كفاءه الاستمطار الصناعي في الارض من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% ان شاء الله وسوف تساعدنا
باذن الله في الاسهام على مكافحه التصحر
ومشاريع السعوديه لرؤيه 2030 مثل الرياض
الخ ضراء وشرق الاوسط الاخضر باذن الله